how about 50 shades of grey folks did  you read that i read some of it oh it  was painful everyone i knew read it  secretly yeah or not so secretly yeah  well it was a funny thing to see happen  because it was happening if i remember  correctly right at the same time as the  metoo movement that makes perfect sense  psychologically because if you get a  reaction that's too far in one direction  then it calls for a fantasy in the other  direction it's like well sex only can  take place between people of equal power  whatever the hell that means it sounds  like a fun sexual experience well that's  part of the reason why relationships  between say undergraduates and graduate  students are hypothetically verboten  which i think by the way is a mistake  because are you an adult or not i'm not  a fan of promiscuity or one night stands  or any casual sexual relationships for  that matter